[Music]
absolutely hilarious very funny and I'm
curious now because very funny stuff but
I detect some truth in what you're
talking about for example you City is on
us just wanting to clear that up that's
our show
good night no you you talk about your
girlfriend and how you introduce your
girlfriend to your did you introduce
your girlfriend sure she's met my family
now a couple times and it was great the
only thing that was tricky was when we
started dating she's a female my
girlfriends and then I have all these
friends that are females so then I
thought when we started dating I was
like oh great they'll all get along
no not even a little at the beginning
like I don't I don't mean to make any
generalizations about women because I
don't know anything about women but I
have noticed that like women can be
friends with each other but you can't
force them to hang out with each other
but you couldn't do a heist with women
does that make sense like Ocean's eleven
with women wouldn't work because two
would keep breaking off to talk trash
about the other night
not even talking trash just say weird
passive-aggressive things to each other
while they break into the casino as I go
I love how you just wear anything why
they haven't made that movie it can't
work now I can you are a writer and
starting out live as I was like fifty
years ago you are along with Bill Hader
you're responsible the two of you have
created a character that's really caught
on probably one of most popular
characters they've had recently Stefon I
think we have you it's it's an
interesting creative process where are
you actually trying surprise
Bill Hader a little bit when he's
performing the character when he's about
to do them on air yeah Ivan builds
absolutely brilliant he's made that
character so funny and it's really fun
to write those with him but sometimes
the first times we were doing them he
being he's a real professional but he
would just break because he liked it he
started he started laughing because he
liked the jokes and just started
laughing and tried to control it and it
was really funny and so I figured it'd
be fun to keep messing with him so that
he laughs every time right so I just
started putting new jokes on the cue
cards in between dress and air so he's
he's alive and he's seeing jokes he's
never seen before for the first time
well just so that he wouldn't trip up
over the wording because if you read a
cue card you wouldn't might not
understand it but I'll go up to him and
I'll be like there's a new club owner
and it's Bologna Danza and then he walks
right out so I'll add something like his
Stefan does these runs of you know the
descriptions of what are at these
nightclubs so I think in the fall we did
one and I put in a shaved lion that
looks like Mario Batali that was that we
put in to spud webs one spud Webb was at
one club and then spud Webb was at
another club later and then one time we
did this twelve days of Christmas thing
and instead of two turtledoves it was
Taylor Negron and I decided I heard
anyone mention David I mean he's great
comedian right yeah but he's not
discussed a lot because he's at this
Christmas Club with Stefan
but I didn't have a new joke but I was
like I need to throw bill off somehow I
have to be unprofessional about this so
I just printed up a photo of actor
comedian Taylor Negron and I signed it
to bill thank you for never making fun
of me on Weekend Update so he broke and
that's yeah that's a big banner tune he
was like you better do it that's what
your job is to ruin his and ruin his
life very funny stuff John Mulaney new
in town is gonna be available on CD and
on DVD Tuesday Tuesday yeah so watch out
for that and thank you so much for being
here really hilarious
[Applause]